was talking to Clay as we were sitting
at the table last night Ty clay Staffing
myself just like how important and big
of a summer this is like how locked in
we need to be no I don't think this is
it I'll say it right here for you and
this isn't it we plan on doing this
thing again that's the plan obviously
this is a business and things has to
take place I get that but we plan on
doing this again and the first thing he
said he said hell yeah I still want to
be an All-Star again I still want to win
more check I want to do all of these
things again and like that was great
number one to just be able to sit there
and have that conversation like you
always talk about like bands breaking up
and like this thing you're too big and
that thing get too big and like to still
have those conversations 11 years later
that's why we win and that's why we will
win again